when did you first fall in love with
robotics or even computer science more
in general computer science first
at a fairly young age robotics happened
much later
i think my first
interesting introduction to computers
was
in the late 80s
when we got our first computer i think
was
an ibm i think ibm it remember those
things that had like a turbo button
in the front you would press it and you
know make make the thing goes faster
did they already have floppy disks yeah
yeah yeah like the
the 5.4 inch ones
i think there was a bigger inch so good
one something then five inches and three
inches
yeah i think that was the five i don't
know maybe that was before that was the
giant plates and i didn't get that
uh but it was definitely not the not the
three inch ones
uh anyway so that that you know we got
that uh
computer i spent the first a few
months just you know playing video games
uh as you would expect
i got bored of that uh so i uh started
messing around
and uh trying to figure out how to you
know make the thing
do other stuff got into uh
exploring programming and a couple of
years
later i got to a point where
i actually wrote a game uh a lot of
games and
a game developer a japanese game
developer actually offered to buy it for
me for you know a few hundred bucks but
you know for for a kid
in russia that's a big deal that's a big
deal yeah i did not take the deal
wow integrity yeah i i instead stupidity
yes that was not the most acute
financial move that i made in my life
you know looking back at it now uh i
instead put it well you know i had a
reason i i put it online
uh it was what did you call it back in
the days it was a freeware i think
right it was not open source but you
could upload the binaries you put the
game online and the idea was that you
know people
like it and then they you know
contribute and they send you a little
donations right so i did my quick math
of like you know
of course you know thousands and
millions of people are going to play my
game send me a couple bucks a piece you
know
should definitely do that as i said not
yeah not the best finder you're already
playing with business models at that
yeah remember what language it was
what programming it was which what
pascal pasco
and they had a graphical component so
then text based yeah yeah it was
uh like uh i think you know 300 320 by
uh whatever it was i think that kind of
the earlier that's the pga
resolution right and i actually think
the reason why this company wanted to
buy it is not like the fancy graphics
or the implementation it was maybe the
idea uh of
my actual game but the idea of the game
okay
well one of the things it's so funny i
used to play this game called golden axe
and the simplicity of the graphics
and something about the simplicity of
the music like
it still haunts me i don't know if
that's a childhood thing i don't know if
that's the same thing for call of duty
these days for young kids
but i still think that the
simple one the games are simple that
simple purity makes for
like allows your imagination to take
over and thereby creating a more magical
experience
like now with better and better graphics
it feels like
your imagination doesn't get to uh
create worlds
which is kind of interesting um it could
be just an old man on a porch like
waving at kids these days that have no
respect but i
still think that graphics almost get in
the way of the experience
i don't know flip it bird yeah
i don't know if the imagination gets
closed i don't
yet but that that's more about games
that up like that's more like tetris
world where they optimally
masterfully like
create a fun short-term dopamine
experience
versus i'm more referring to like
role-playing games where there's like a
story you can live in it for
months or years like uh
there's an elder scroll series which is
probably my favorite set of games
that was a magical experience and that
the graphics were terrible
the characters were all randomly
generated but they're i don't know
that's it pulls you in there's a story
it's like
an interactive version of an elder
scrolls
tolkien world and you get to live in it
i don't know
i miss it it's one of the things that
suck about being an
adult is there's no you have to live in
the real world as opposed to
the elder scrolls world you know
whatever brings you joy right
minecraft right minecraft is a great
example you create like it's not the
fancy graphics but it's the
creation of your own worlds yeah that
one is crazy
you know one of the pitches for being a
parent that people tell me
is that you can like use the excuse of
parenting to
to go back into the video game world and
like
like that's like you know father-son
father-daughter time
but really you just get to play video
games with your kids so
you